7 avril 2015 grégory gary astier le
maire de maurepas ferme son centre
aquatique pour raisons de sécurité
la structure devrait renaître grâce à
une association avec coignard elancourt
on est trois communes touchées
vous savez
parce que aussi il n'y a pas eu
l'entretien nécessaire qui a été fait
auparavant
il ya quelques années donc bien sûr on
est trois communes fortement touché nos
enfants aussi
et bien sûr il faut accéder tout cela et
en même temps c'est beau aujourd'hui
plus difficile de trouver les moyens
une intercommunalité aidé par saint
quentin en yvelines la communauté
d'agglomération a débloqué 2,4 millions
d'euros pour le projet nous sommes
lancés dans la procédure de l'assistance
à maîtrise d ouvrage en concession avec
une délégation de service public pour la
gestion de ce futur équipement et sa
construction
donc nous avons délibéré les trois
villes pour lancer la démo qui va nous
aider à constituer le projet dans le
détail avant de lancer les appels
d'offres en concession c'est une
concession sur 25 ans nous allons
confier donc un délégataire est assez
risque également nous avons confiée à un
concessionnaire nous allons confier le
financement la maintenance de
l'établissement le fonctionnement de
l'établissement et les différentes
gestions qui peuvent concerner les
renouvellement d'équipements notamment
pendant la période des 25 ans de
concession
une concertation avec les habitants va
être lancée dans l'année la destruction
du bâtiment actuel devrait être
effective en 2019